[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF ALBERTSON: Please join
me in welcoming to Google
Seattle, Masha Alyokhina.
[APPLAUSE]
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Hi.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Masha is a
founding member of Pussy Riot
and a political activist.
She is also an author,
poet, musician,
mother of a young
son, and an actor,
having appeared as herself in
an episode of "House of Cards"
and on stage this
week in Seattle
in the Belarus Free Theater's
production of "Burning
Doors," which is a
play based on her life
and those of two
other activists, which
runs through this
Sunday at On the Boards.
And tickets remain available.
I understand it's
a great production.
Her memoir of her time as
a prisoner of conscience
in Russia, "Riot Days," was
published three days ago.
And as I told Masha, I am
roughly halfway through reading
it myself.
With her fellow Pussy Riot
member, Nadezhda Tolokonnikova,
she founded Zona Prava,
an organization which
defends prisoners' rights.
She's a recipient of the
Lennon Ono Grant for Peace
as well as the Hannah Arendt
prize for Political Thought.
So I've mentioned
that books will
be for sale after we're
done and, I think,
a bit about the format.
So let's get right
into some questions.
Are you ready?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: So
many things about me.
I even don't know.
JEFF ALBERTSON: OK, well, if
any question is out of bounds
or uncomfortable for you,
that's perfectly all right.
But let's get right to it.
I want to get to the events that
are the focus of "Riot Days."
But before we do,
could you just tell us
a bit about your
life in Russia prior
to the founding of Pussy Riot?
You know, where were
you born and raised?
What was your life
like growing up?
Maybe a bit about
your education and how
you formed your social and
political consciousness.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: I
was born in Moscow
in 1988, which is an
amazing time in Russia.
It's Perestroika time.
So it's kind of the
end of Soviet Union
and rising up Russia.
So in my passport,
I'm from USSR,
but it's last year
of USSR, actually.
My mother, she's a programmist.
And my father, he is a
mathematics professor.
And I was growing
up with my mother.
So I met my father
when I was a teenager.
And there were almost no
talking politics in our family.
But somehow, I was kind
of a problematic child.
So I changed five schools.
All of them I left
by myself, because I
hated the system of education,
so-called education.
Because it's totally Soviet
Union system in which
they want you to follow the
rules but not asking questions.
And I love questions.
So that's how I
think it all started.
And before Pussy Riot, I was--
well, it's a big circle of
totally different people.
For example, I started all
my activism from ecology.
When I knew that some
government officials close
to former presidents
of Russia, Medvedev,
want to cut the forest I really
love, I start a campaign,
like, a small campaign.
We were like five people
meeting on the subway
and collecting signatures.
But after one year, there
was more than 10,000 people
around Russia, and we won.
But in the end of the
story, I was quite--
well, I understood that it's
a totally wrong situation when
you need to do, every
day, activism for,
like, making results of one
signature of one fucking
government official.
I started to knew about
different forms of protest.
And I start to read
about political art.
I start to meet
different people.
And that's how I think
Pussy Riot started.
JEFF ALBERTSON: So there
was a significant transition
in Russian society at the
start of the new millennium
between Boris Yeltsin
and Vladimir Putin,
as President of Russia.
And in your book,
you write about this.
You note that at the time
Putin said, we need stability.
And then you go on
to say, stability
was what he called himself.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Could
you expand on that a bit?
What is this notion of
stability in your mind?
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
Well, yes, this is
one of his favorite
words, stability.
But it's hypocritic shit.
It's not about stability.
It's about being a
president until he will die
and stealing money
from Russian people
and spending them
in their circles.
So it's not about stability.
Actually, we went to the
Cathedral of Christ the Savior,
because in the beginning
of the third term,
Putin started to use
church for approving
his endless presidency, saying
that he is kind of sent by God
to be a president of Russia.
And Patriarch Kirill, who was
the head of the Orthodox Church
and very influential
person in Russian society,
started to approve this, saying
that true Christians should not
go to the demonstrations
and so on.
Well, so we decide to do a song.
[LAUGHS]
JEFF ALBERTSON: So
Pussy Riot was formed.
You formed it with
several other women.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Not only women.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Not only women?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Also men?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah, why not?
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF ALBERTSON: Very well.
And as it came
together you began
to organize what
you called actions.
Could you talk about
a typical action?
You write, for
example, in the book
about an action at Lobnoye
Mesto, which is a large stone
platform near Red Square and
outside the Kremlin walls.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yes.
JEFF ALBERTSON:
What happened there,
and what was a
typical action like?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Action
is a form of political art
when you're doing an action.
So before the
Christ, the Savior,
we went to the Red Square,
which is the heart of, I think,
political field of Russia.
And we came there with a
song, "Putin Pisses Himself,"
his pants actually.
I think, yes, that's
correct translation.
And that's, I think, how the
officials knew that we exist.
How you want to describe?
So the action usually
should be prepared.
So it's different
from, for example,
classical political rally.
So you're doing-- you should be
prepared, because you will not
have a second chance to do it.
I mean, you will have,
but a different place.
And different place
means different contexts
and different statements.
So we went to the Red
Square, because we felt
that we need to protest there.
Because that was a time,
of January of 2012,
when, before the elections,
almost all the Russia
was protesting.
I think it's a little
bit similar of what's
going on now in
the United States.
Because somehow Trump became
a match for the people
to stand up and to
spread the word.
JEFF ALBERTSON:
So that brings us
a bit forward in the story
to the "Punk Prayer."
So this was the action
that led to your arrest
and detention and the trial and,
ultimately, your imprisonment.
It took place in a
large Russian Orthodox
Church in central Moscow in the
Cathedral of Christ the Savior.
So I want to interject that
I visited this place in 1989
during the Soviet period.
Our tourist guides
took us to this site.
It was a swimming pool,
a large outdoor swimming
pool at the time.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: It's true.
JEFF ALBERTSON: A
cathedral had existed
from the 19th
century on that site
but was torn down in 1931
in an anti-religious purge.
And then, since the fall
of the Soviet Union,
a cathedral has been
rebuilt on the site.
But you note in your book
that the cathedral is not
actually owned by the
Russian Orthodox Church.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: No.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Nor is it
always used in ways that might
associate with the church.
Could you say a
bit more about how
Pussy Riot selected this site
for the "Punk Prayer" action?
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
Yeah, it's not-- well,
it's not just church.
It's a huge complex--
like upper church, let's
say, and lower church.
And in the upper
church, upper church
is a symbol of this
collaboration between Putin
and Patriarch, because Patriarch
usually during his speeches
there.
But in the lower church--
and both of them do
not officially, by law,
belong to Russian Orthodox
Church organization.
And there are a lot
of kind of facilities
there, like laundry,
shop of souvenirs,
car wash, and halls,
like rental halls,
rental rooms for parties,
where you can not only
have a party but rent some
Japanese technics for music
and invite some
musical band there.
And generator of, like,
heavy smoke, easy smoke.
There's balloons and so on.
And so all this list of
what you can do there,
you can find on the
official website.
And usually, if you
revere something,
you start to read about
this place and so on.
So we went to the
official website,
and we were quite surprised.
And well, I mean, we
didn't ask any permission
to make a song there.
But yeah, and the
song was protest.
I think-- let's say, it's a
big drama for our country.
Because during the
whole Soviet period,
Christianity was banned in
Russia, in Soviet Union.
And thousands of people
were killed, tortured,
sent to the endless prison
terms just for being Christians,
just for praying, for
celebrating Christmas.
And now we have a
situation where, I mean,
Christianity is
used by Chekists,
by the same organization
which were repressing them
for almost a century.
And this is very sad.
And I think the difference
for political art,
between, for example, political
activism, is not providing only
one right decision.
It's about asking
questions which are not
being asked before and which are
uncomfortable for government,
for example, or for
any authorities.
So that's what we did.
We didn't say that we know how,
for example, the church should
exist in the right way.
We just said that we think
that it's wrong how it is.
JEFF ALBERTSON: In the days
after the "Punk Prayer,"
you went into hiding in
Moscow for a number of days,
and then you were arrested--
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah.
JEFF ALBERTSON: --and detained.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: That
was almost a year.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Yes.
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
Because we changed
flats, conspiracy flats
every day, changed phones,
changed SIM cards and so on.
So yeah, it's one
of my favorite part.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF ALBERTSON: So your
first stop in your detention
was in Moscow, as
I understand it.
Where you spent some
months awaiting trial.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: No.
JEFF ALBERTSON: No?
Not so long?
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
When they arrest you,
they put you to Petrovka.
It's like the oldest prison,
oldest jail in Moscow,
like from the sad period
and so on, from monarchy.
So they put you there, and
there you spend five, six days.
And after they put
you to the jail
were investigation,
court, and sentence.
So it's about eight
months you are
spending in the
women's jail, which
is the only one in Moscow.
JEFF ALBERTSON: And you
described Petrovka as a place--
for example, it was so cold, and
the building was so porous that
the prisoners used dough
from their bread ration--
MASHA ALYOKHINA: It's jail.
JEFF ALBERTSON: --and
sanitary napkins--
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
It's Moscow jail.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Moscow jail--
to stuff into
cracks in the walls
to try to insulate
their room themselves.
So during this
time when you were
in detention awaiting
trial, what kind of access
did you have to legal
counsel, to a lawyer,
and also to your family
and others on the outside?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: I had
an access to lawyer.
But, well, I think
it's a bit different.
So you have visits with lawyer
in the room in another building
from where your cell is.
And of course, it's
all listened and so on.
So they can use any of your
talks anywhere, not only
in investigation protocols.
They can use it in governmental
media, for example.
Because all the media,
as you know, in Russia,
all the big media belongs
to friends of Putin.
So they provide
everything what they
accept from the administration
of the president.
And about family, to have
a visit with your family,
you should have a signed
paper from your investigator.
And our investigator, he
somehow lost about 10 papers
where I ask to this visit.
So no visits during
the investigation.
After the trial,
I had one visit,
but it's kind of hard to see--
I mean, to see your son
between this glass and so on.
JEFF ALBERTSON: What was--
except for that visit, what
was the total amounts of time
you were separated
from your son?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Well, I've
been in prison for two years.
But when they sent
me after the sentence
to the penal colony, which is
3,000 kilometers to Moscow,
I had once at three months
visits with my family.
So they came to the
penal colony to visit me.
JEFF ALBERTSON: So you
were charged with--
in English, it
translates to hooliganism
motivated by religious hatred.
You recall your
reaction when you
were told that was the
charge against you?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: I
don't know, yeah.
I was quite surprised,
because the law in Russia
exists in the way that if
you have just hooliganism,
it's not a criminal crime.
So you can get up
to 15 days in jail.
But if they find this
motivation of hatred,
it's up to seven years.
And well, this kind of
"hatred" can be different.
It can be political
hatred, social hatred,
and religious one,
which they somehow
found in us, in our song.
And that was hard to say--
a special part of the trial
of proving that we really
hated the church, they
said, and Christianity,
which was fucking absurd.
JEFF ALBERTSON: The
prosecutors analyzed
the lyrics of the songs
in your performance.
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
Special experts.
Special experts
analyzed our song
and found that the phrase
holy shit means hatred
to whole Christianity.
As if you're saying
holy shit, it
means that you hate all
Christian believings
and church itself.
Yes, I mean, it's
official, official.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF ALBERTSON: So the trial?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: As often you
repeat holy shit, it means,
like, you more and
more hate the church.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF ALBERTSON: I understand at
the conclusion of the trial--
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
And there are people
who really believed that.
JEFF ALBERTSON: They believed
the testimony of these experts?
So at the conclusion
of your trial,
you were sentenced to
two years in prison,
and you were transported
to a prison camp in Perm.
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
Berezniki, yeah.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Berezniki.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: It's actually
a small city in Perm region.
And Boris Yeltsin,
who was before Putin,
he was grown up in that city.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Oh.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah,
he was study there.
And he was, well, totally not
the president, as you know.
JEFF ALBERTSON:
What a small world.
Can you tell us a bit
about the prison camp?
What was the environment
like for you?
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
In Russia, we have
Soviet system of Soviet prison
system or post-Soviet prison
system.
So we don't have prisons.
We have penal colonies,
let's say, or labor camps.
So it's camp.
It's like a strange village
with barracks, buildings.
For example, two
floors building.
In one floor exist one unit.
And in one unit it's 100 people.
So all of them are living
together, sleeping together
in one bedroom, and
having, for example, three
toilets for everybody.
And it's no hot
water, no medicine,
which is the main problem.
And it's necessary to work.
So all the prisoners
work in the fabric,
which is another part of the
zone or the penal colony.
And the most cynical
thing that the work
is sewing police uniform and
uniform for Russian army.
[SIGHS]
Yeah, they are almost
not paid for that.
So it's like two, three
dollars for month as a salary.
And usually people who have
no support from the outside
should somehow
decide what they will
buy-- cigarettes or toothpaste.
Well, when I came there--
the transportation is
another kind of story--
I was quite surprised, because,
well, all these women start
to tell me what is going on.
But they didn't do
anything against it.
And I asked, why?
Why you just say that
you will not go to work?
And some of these people were
working for administration
as, let's say, spies.
And if you're saying
something like that,
it means that you're kind of
preparing of this organization
of regimen.
And they put me into
solitary confinement
for two months and two months,
so almost five months in total.
And start to make different
kinds of pressure to me.
So we, together with my
lawyer and my friends,
decide to go to the
court against them.
And after two months, we won.
And that was the first
court against prison guards
in this penal colony, and
everybody were quite surprised.
JEFF ALBERTSON: You
won your release
from solitary confinement?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: No, no, no.
I won a court against prison
guards, against their--
for example, if they find it's--
OK.
For example, they want to
punish you inside prison,
so how they can do it.
They are finding
that you somehow
violated the regimen, the rules
of prison, the official law.
After this finding,
they writing a paper.
And this paper
means that you are
kind of disciplinary punished.
They can, I mean, it's
a whole process there,
like official one.
It's like a small
court against--
a small court inside the prison.
So they wrote a number of
these papers against me.
And I went to the
court to appeal.
And when I won, eight
people from prison guards
were fired, because
they broke a law.
It's them who did it.
And they start to kind
of improve conditions.
So they start to
recover barracks,
put up salaries,
yeah, these things.
JEFF ALBERTSON:
You were released
from your sentence a bit early.
What do you think
motivated the government
to declare an
amnesty that impacted
your case at the end of 2013?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: It was a
month before Olympic games.
So as you know, the Olympic
games, so the media and--
JEFF ALBERTSON: In Sochi?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: In Sochi,
yes, it came to Russia.
And somehow Putin,
his team decide
to make good faces for
the West and released
us and Mikhail Khodorkovsky, who
was also political prisoner who
spent 10 years in penal
colony, who used to be
a Russian oligarch in '90s.
So they released three of us and
some other political prisoners
from Arctic Sunrise case.
I don't know.
Do you know it was national
for Russian ecologists
and Greenpeace?
It's another story, anyway.
So they released a number
of political prisoners,
saying that, hi,
guys, we don't have
political prisoners in Russia.
We are OK.
[LAUGHTER]
But we went to the Sochi
after a month, I think,
a month, a week.
And that was another story,
because we made an action
there, and that was
totally another Russian
that we remembered.
JEFF ALBERTSON: You were
assaulted in Sochi at least
once.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah,
Cossacks, Cossacks with
[MAKES WHIPPING SOUND].
JEFF ALBERTSON: Whips.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Whips.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Yeah.
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
[LAUGHS] Not only them.
JEFF ALBERTSON: May I
open it to some questions
from my colleagues?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Let me
pass around the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Masha.
So what are your main learnings
from your life and basically--
MASHA ALYOKHINA: What?
AUDIENCE: Your main learnings?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Learnings.
AUDIENCE: Is that--
did you hear?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what is
the main message you
want to bring to this country?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: I think
every learning is important.
And I wrote the
book just to show
the one example of how it
is possible to make a choice
and act.
But I believe that history of
any country, it doesn't matter.
Russia, United
States, Great Britain
are made by people, not
by political leaders,
but by all of us.
And each of us has own story.
And all these
stories is actually
a history of the country.
So I know it doesn't sound
like a statement or a message.
But I think this is
what I want to say.
JEFF ALBERTSON: Next
question for Masha?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious,
in the sort of spectrum
of a different kind
of political action,
from more to less radical,
through art, through marching,
also different things people
can do under a regime that's
oppressive, which are the most
effective to actually bring
about change, in your opinion?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Any
honest thing, actually.
I mean, we have one effective
manager, whose name was Stalin,
and that was quite effective.
But I think brought us
to not work like that.
It's about what's in your heart.
And, for example, I was a
studier of political art
or any art except poetry.
So I never thought that
it will happen with me.
Never.
But things are
happening sometimes.
So it's most important--
do not lose yourself and
do not afraid to speak out.
It doesn't matter
where it's going on.
Maybe it's a situation in the
class where all the students
are silent, and
you just stand up
and say something to your
teacher that you are not agree.
This is totally the same than
going to the cathedral for me.
It's the same level.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
What brings you joy?
And what are your
future artistic plans?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Well,
I like the reaction.
I like when I am doing
something and it works.
And I like swim.
It's different things, but--
[LAUGHTER]
And future plans?
I don't have plans.
I'm usually, like,
doing what I feel.
JEFF ALBERTSON: So you've been a
citizen activist and a prisoner
of conscience in what most
neutral observers would
certainly call an
authoritarian regime.
What advice would you offer
to people in other countries
around the world who
might be concerned
about creeping authoritarianism
in their own societies?
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Advice?
Mm, I mean, when we
started Pussy Riot,
we were inspired by
movements from US a lot,
from radicals, from [INAUDIBLE].
So it's you guys
who give us advices.
So really, I think you have
an amazing culture if we're
speaking about freedom.
I mean, United
States was created
as a culture of freedom.
So what do I say can give you?
That's a very strange question.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF ALBERTSON: Thank you.
So with that, we'll
come to a close.
Masha Alyokhina,
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]..
MASHA ALYOKHINA:
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
How you know Russian?
JEFF ALBERTSON: At school.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Really?
He was learning
Russian in school?
JEFF ALBERTSON: I was, yes.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: It's popular?
JEFF ALBERTSON: No.
MASHA ALYOKHINA: No.
[LAUGHTER]
But why did you decide
to learn Russian?
JEFF ALBERTSON: Well,
it was the Cold War.
[LAUGHTER]
MASHA ALYOKHINA: Oh.
Right.
JEFF ALBERTSON: It seemed
like a valuable skill.